[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم الى هذه الحلقه
من برنامج مورا الخبر خلال جلسه استماعا
امام لجنه الاعتمادات الماليه بمجلس
النواب قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي كارتر
قال ان امد الحمله العسكريه ضد تنظيم
الدوله في سوريا والعراق سيكون اطول من
ثلاث سنوات وقال ان تحديد السنوات الثلاث
يتعلق باسباب دستوريه وقانونيه نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي الاعتبارات السياسيه
والعسكريه وراء توقع ان تمتد العمليات ضد
تنظيم الدوله لاكثر من ثلاث سنوات
وكيف يؤثر هذا التصريح على ارض الواقع
وميدان المعركه وكيف يفهمه تنظيم
[موسيقى]
الدوله جدل عنيف داخل الولايات المتحده
بشان الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه حيال تنظيم
الدوله التي يقول منتقد اوباما من
الجمهوريين انها محدوده عسكريا بدرجه لا
تكفل لها النجاح يترافق ذلك مع قلق متزايد
بشان انتشار تنظيم الدوله في المزيد من
المناطق هذه هي الاجواء التي احاطت بقول
وزير الدفاع الامريكي انه لا يضمن ان
تسترق العمليات العسكريه ضد تنظيم الدوله
ثلاث سنوات فقط ربما يدعم هذا القول تصريح
رئيسي يدعمه تصريح رئيس لجنه الاعتمادات
الماليه بمجلس النواب الامريكي بعدم وجود
استراتيجيه لدى اداره اوباما في العراق
وقد يعمق ايضا شكوك اطراف دوليه واقليميه
حيال خطط واشنطن بشان النظام
السوري الحمله على تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
ستستغرق زمنا اطول من ثلاث سنوات يقول ذلك
للكونغرس وزير الدفاع الامريكي اشتون
كارتر ويوضح بان السنوات الثلاث التي
حددها اوباما سببها دستوري وقانوني ولا
صله لها بامد الحمله نفسها تلك تحتاج زمنا
يطول ربما الى نحو 30 عاما على ما رجح
وزير الدفاع السابق ليون بانيتا امر دفع
كثيرين للتساؤل ما اذا كان الحديث يتعلق
بدحر تنظيم ام خوض حرب عالميه لتفكيك
المنطقه واعاده ترتيبها من جديد
الاستراتيجيه اذا ليست عسكريه فواشنطن
اطاحت بصدام حسين وكان لديه واحد من اكبر
جيوش المنطقه في نحو 40 يوما بل سياسيه
على ما يذهب كثيرون فالهدف الحقيقي
بالنسبه للبعض ليس هزيمه التنظيم بل
اتخاذه ساترا لاهداف اخرى لا تتحقق من دون
خلق عدو مباشر تتصف افعاله بالف جاجه
والبدائيه وتلك تكفي لتجييش العواصم
واغماض العيون عن جوهر الحمله العسكريه
وغايتها يفسر ذلك حرص واشنطن على ما يمكن
اعتباره فصلا للمسارات فمصير الاسد ليس
مرتبط لديها بشكل مباشر بتنظيم الدوله
وكذا ما يوصف بعمليه تنظيف الاسطبلات في
العراق بعد خروج القوات الامريكيه منها
فسوريا تدعم اداره اوباما المعارضه
المعتدله فعل يبدو بطيئا ومتدرج ولا يعلم
ما اذا كان هدفه تهيئتها لقتال الاسد ام
تسلم الحكم من بعده تتفق مع انقره على
تدريبها وذاك جهد قد يحتاج سنوات ويتسم
بالغموض غير البناء فيما يت تعلق بغاياتها
خاصه ان الامريكيين لا سواهم يعادون
تنظيمات تحارب الاسد فعليا على الارض
وتسعى لخلعه عسكريا الامر نفسه ينطبق على
المسار العراقي هناك تدعم واشنطن الحكومه
العراقيه وقبلها المكون الكردي في الحرب
على تنظيم الدوله لكنها تلمح احيانا الى
حل اكثر تعقيدا لازمه الحكم في العراق
القائم على المحاصصه الطائفيه وانه يحتاج
زمنا وانخراط من المكونات في العمليه
السياسيه في الوقت الذي تغض الطرف عن تدخل
قوه اقليميه في شؤونه لها انحياز لا يخفى
لمكون دون غيره امر قد يعني التغطي بتنظيم
الدوله للضغط على اطراف الصراع على كلا
المسارين اما لاعاده ترتيب المنطقه على
اساس طائفي كما يتخوف البعض او تقاسمها
وظيفيا مع بعض القوى في الاقليم وكلا
الاحتمالين وسواهما يتطلب امدا زمنيا اكبر
بكثير من الوقت الذي يمكن هزيمه تنظيم
الدوله
خلاله وضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع ضيفين او
ضيوفنا من واشنطن جيف جوردن المسؤول
السابق في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ومن
عمان الدكتور حيدر سعيد مستشار المركز
العراقي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه وايضا من
اربيل الدكتور ناجح الميزان الامين العام
المؤتمر التاسيسي لاقليم صلاح الدين نرحب
بضيوفنا جميعا ونبدا معك استاذ جيف جوردن
من واشنطن نريد ان نفهم هذه التصريحات
لوزير الدفاع الامريكي التي يقول فيها ان
عمليات العسكريه ضد تنظيم الدوله قد تمتد
ربما اكثر من ثلاث سنوات على اي اساس بنى
الوزير
برايك هذا
الاعتقاد
مرحبا يا خديجه شكرا
جزيلا انا دائما سعيد جدا ان اشارك في
برنامجكم اعتقد ان الوزير اراد ان يوضح
للشعب الامريكي والعالم ما هو واقعي وحال
ان الامر على الارجاع قد يتطلب اكثر من
ثلاث سنوات لالحاق الهزيمه بداعش وسبب
الرئيس حصل على ترخيص لم ثلاث سنوات لعمل
العسكري هو ان هناك متطلبات دستوريه
وقانونيه لكي يوافق الكونغرس على
ذلك ولكن هناك ادراك بان كما قال اشتن
كارتر ان الامر سيتطلب اكثر من ثلاث سنوات
وبالتالي اعتقد الامر هو حقيقه واقعه
واعتقد المهم جدا انه يوضح ذلك وان
الولايات المتحده يجب ان تعد نفسها لحرب
طويله لالحاق الهزيمه بداعش والمتطرفين
الذين يهددنا ويهددون حلفائنا في المنطقه
طيب نود ان نفهم معك هذه الاسباب
القانونيه والدستوريه سيد جيف
جوردن لدينا ثلاثه سلطات في الحكومه
السلطه التنفيذيه الرئيس والتشريعيه
الكونجرس
والقضائيه المحكمه العليا هذه السلطات
الثلاثه مستقله بموجب الدستور وبالتالي ي
السلطه ان تقوم بضربات جويه والرئيس لا
يستطيع ان ان يقوم باوامر اطلاق اوامر
الحرب كما يشاء والفتره ضدها وبالتالي اذا
ارد ان يقوم بعمليات طويله او حروب كما
حصل في افغانستان والعراق وكما حال
بالنسبه لداعش حاليا في العراق سوريا لابد
ان هناك تخويل باستخدام القوه العسكريه
يوافق عليه الكونغرس يخرج الطلب من البيت
الابيض ولابد ان يوافق عليه الكونجرس
والقيام بذلك وفي هذه الجلسات الاستماع
كما قال اشتن كارتر انه يفهم انه كان هناك
انتقادات شديده في الولايات المتحده لماذا
القول فقط ثلاث سنوات هذا ليس واقعي لذلك
هو اراد ان يطلع الكونغرس بانه يفهم ان
الامر يتطلب اكثر من ثلاث سنوات ويامل ان
الكوس سوف يوافق على تخويل استخدام القوه
لفتره طويله وهو يعلم انه ثلاث سنوات هي
الفتره التي يريدها الرئيس وان الرئيس لن
يبقى اكثر من سنه قادمتين وبالتالي اعتقد
ان الكونغرس قد فهم رساله وزير الدفاع
وسوف
يمدد تخويل استخدام القوه العسكريه
وبالتالي فان الولايات المتحده ستكون في
حاله حرب اكثر من ثلاث سنوات لالحاق
الهزيمه بداعش والخلايا الارهابيه الامر
طلب وقتا طويلا العراق وسوريا وان ذلك
يهدد حلفائنا في المنطقه وفي الولايات وفي
اوروبا وبالتالي يجب ان دمره داعش قبل ان
تحصل تس 119 جديده في الولايات المتحده
الدكتور حيدر سعيد في البدايه الناس كانت
تعتقد ان المساله قد تستغرق سته اشهر قد ت
تستغرق على ابعد تقدير ربما سنه ولكن
نتحدث الان يتحدث وزير الدفاع الامريكي عن
ثلاث سنوات على الاقل ربما اكثر من ذلك
اليس
كثيرا اولا شكرا استذ قدي احيك واحيي ضيفك
الكريمين يعني لا انا ما اتصور منذ بدايه
المعركه ضد تنظيم الدوله وما بات يعرف
اعلاميا باسم داعش
ا منذ
البدايه لا اعتقد ان خبيرا قال ان المعركه
ستستغرق اشهرا فقط يعني اولا منذ الايام
الاولى بعد سقوط الموصل في 9عه حزيران
الماضي الرئيس اوباما نفسه قال ان المعركه
ستستغرق ثلاث سنوات يعني بالمناسبه تعبير
ثلاث سنوات هو اصلا ورد في خطبه للرئيس
اوباما وتجربتنا يعني في العراق تحديدا مع
تنظيم القاعده في سنوات 2006 و2007 و2008
وما نتج عنه من تنظيمات الصحوه نحن نتحدث
عن معارك طويله الامت هذه ليست حربا
تقليديه حرب بين جيوش تقليديه هذه حرب
تخاض ضد
تنظيم شبكي يفيد من البيئه السياسيه المح
تقنا فبالتالي اولا المعركه هي ليست معركه
عسكريه فقط نحن نتحدث عن جهود سياسيه
لاصلاح الازمه السياسيه التي انتجت مثل
مثل هذا التنظيم فبالتالي لا انا
اعتقد المعركه طويله منذ البدايه كل
الخبراء كنا نتحدث عن معركه طويله الامد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي ربما الان اراد ان
ينبه انه حتى الثلاث سنوات التي وردت
في يعني في كلام الرئيس اوباما حتى هذه قد
لا تبدو كافيه وربما ربما ربما الان بدات
تبدو بعض الايقاعات المختلفه فيما يخص
مواجهه تنظيم داعش يعني الان نحن نتحدث عن
معركه تكريد في
العراق يعني بدات بعض التسريبات تتحدث عن
خلاف امريكي عراقي وربما يعني ايران وراء
بعض الاطراف
العراقيه حول معركه تكريت يبدو الان هناك
ايقاعات مختلفان في تصور المعركه مع داعش
الايقاع العراقي
اي يتصور معركه باشهر يجب ان تحسم عسكريا
حتى من دون ال يعني الاطار السياسي او
الترتيبات او التسويات السياسيه الضروريه
وايقاع امريكي اكثر بطا ربما تصريحات وزير
الدفاع الامريكي عبرت عنها لكن يعني اسف
ان اطرت لكن ارد اشير الى بعض الاشياء
المهمه يعني
الجنرال جون الين منسق التحالف الدولي صرح
قبل يومين عن معركه الموصل المفروض اللي
تصير بالربيع قال الى الان لم نكمل
الترتيبات اللازمه لهذه المعركه ومنها
اداره الموصل ما بعد تحريرها من تنظيم
داعش بمعنى انه يجب من الان ان نبني شرطه
محليه هي التي تتولى اداره المدينه او مسك
الارض ما بعد التحرير كانما الجنرال جون
اراد ان يشي الى معكه تعدادات العراقيه لم
تنتبه الى مفاصل اساسيه في المعركه ومنها
التصور حول اداره المدينه ما بعد نعم ولكن
كلما طالت المده كلما كانت لها تداعيات
اكثر تعقيدا على الواقع دكتور ناجح
الميزان يعني هذا التقدير ثلاث سنوات فما
اكثر ما هي تداعيات الممكنه له على ارض
الواقع
احييك ويي ضيفك وجميع المشاهدين بالنسبه
لامريكا احنا يعني عندنا تجربه وياهم
عندما احتلوا العراق ب 2003 صدرت تصريحات
بكبار القاده منها سنحكم العراق حكم مباشر
لمده 25 عام وبالتالي امريكا بين ان محبطه
وبين عندما تكون منتصره ولا توجد مقاومه
تتحدث عن عشرات السنين الحكم
قياده مدنيه او حاكم مدني او مندوب سامي
لم صارت المقاومه امريكا جميع المدد انتهت
وسحبت قواتها لو ناتي طبعا فيه مصداقيه
يعني كلام
المتحدثين فيه كثير من الواقعيه اليوم من
من من 2000 من عام 2000 عندما ضربت برج
التجاره ولحد الان 2015 احنا لمده 15 او
16 عام لم تنتهي القاعده الحرب مع القاعد
بل انتشرت في اماكن كثيره امريكا لما
تتحدث الامريكان عندما يتحدثون عن داعش
بمعنى يتحدثون عن داعش في مالي في بوكو
حرام يتحدثون عن الداعش في مصر يتحدثون في
سوريا في الصومال في جنوب شرق اسيا في
جميع هذه المناطق في اليمن هذا جانب
الجانب الاخر يعلمون الامريكان جيدا عندما
تقاد معارك ضد داعش بالنيابه واي نيا
بالنيابه الايرانيه بمعنى سيكون
هناك وقود لهذه الحرب
وسيكون تقويه وتوسع وكثره للمجندين مع
داعش لان من يقاتلهم في الجانب الاخر هو
قاسم سليماني وهذا تعرفون جميعا ان هناك
داعش تعتمد العداء العقدي مثل ما ايران
والاحزاب الطائفيه ايضا في دراسه لما يحدث
الان في تكريت باي باي دافع وباي معنى
اليوم انه قاسم سليماني يشرف على معركه في
تكريت وما لتكريت من ثار مع ايران وجود
قاسم سليماني يقوي داعش يجعل من لا يفكر
بالانضمام الى داعش كثير يفكر يقول يعني
لماذا لماذا قاسم سليماني السؤال لماذا
تسبح امريكا لقاسم وغير قاسم في سامراء و
في سامراء
يعتذرون ويقولون بعذر انه نحن نحمل عتبات
المقدسه سامر عن تكريت بحدود 60 كيلو في
البيجي حوالي 100 كيلو في اماكن كثيره
وجود قاسم سليماني بهذا الشكل هي اطاله
تعلم امريكا سواء هي سمحت ام لم تسمح هي
تعلم جيدا سيكون هناك حرب طائفيه وكثير من
الخبراء ذهبوا اكثر من ذلك قالوا هذه ال
50 عام ستكون حرب بين المتطرفين السنه
والشيعه فامريكا بالتالي هي لا تخطر عندما
تقول اكثر من ثلاث سنوات هي ترى المنظر
الصوره كامله ليس جزءا في العراق او جزءا
في سوريا او في اليمن او في اماكن اخرى
واليمن بدات معارك اليوم ما فعله الحوثيين
هناك ايضا اكو قاعده وهنا حوثيين وهذا
ولايه يعني القضيه معقده جدا في الشرق
الاوسط واعتقد لا يخالفون الواقع اذا ما
اعتمدنا على الماضي منذ 15 عاما وامريكا
تقاتل داعش من قبلها القاعده وما زالت
موجوده القاعده في كل مكان في فاعتقد يعني
لا تبدع كثيرا عن الواقع اذا ما استشرفت
المستقبل وقالت عر سنوات و 15 سنه انا
اعتقد هذا الكلام فيه شيء من الواقعيه اذا
ما علمنا او نرى الان الادوات التي تحارب
قاعده اي تقدير واقعي جدا يعني اليوم
اليوم من يقول ان داعش اليوم هي ستضعف
وجود قاسم سليماني يقوي داعش وجود قاسم
سليماني ووجود الميليشيات المتطرفه
العقديه بالمقابل ها تقوي داعش لان هناك
خوف من الميليشيات لم يكن يعني يعني لو
كان مثلا لو كانت الحكومه العراقيه قادره
حكومه السيد العبادي لو كانت قادره وعدها
جيش وعندها اجهزه امنيه وطنيه لم استعانت
بالميليشيات لكن هو هذا الواقع هو ما فعله
المالكي وسلم الارض للبلد ل لسيد العبادي
مجموعه من الميليشيات بقياده قاسم سليماني
والقبلات بين القاده المي وقاسم سليماني
في تكريت اعتقد ستقوي في بوكو حرام في
نيجيريا وفي مالي وفي سوريا سيكون هناك تخ
طئ وحرب
طائفيه لكن سنصر النقاش في موضوع
التصريحات فيما يتعلق
ب انعكاس هذه التصريحات على الحمله
العسكريه ضد تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه ولكن
ناخذ في الاول فاصلا قصيرا ثم نعود للنقاش
مع ضيوفنا فلا تذهبوا
بعيدا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش تصريح وزير الدفاع الامريكي
بان امد الحمله العسكريه ضد تنظيم الدوله
في سوريا والعراق سيكون اطول من ثلاث
سنوات لاسباب دستوريه
وقانونيه السيد جيف
جوردن يعني واضح ان هناك اتفاق بينكم بين
الضيوف جميعا على موضوع ان التقدير الزمني
لهذه الحمله يبدو تقديرا واقعيا
ومعقولا ان تستمر الحمله ثلاث سنوات او
ربما اكثر من ثلاث سنوات ولكن هل ستعتمد
هذه
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه المعمول بها ام ان
الوزير وزير الدفاع الامريكي خصوصا وانه
اجتمع مع كبار القاده العسكريين سيعتمد
استراتيجيه جديده في هذه الحمله العسكريه
التي ستستمر اكثر من ثلاث
سنوات
ان هذا سؤال رائع يا خديجه ان
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه هي مجرد جزء واحد
من حمله تدمير داعش علينا ان ندمر
ايديولوجيه داعش التي تغذي التطرف انا ارى
ان داعش هي رد فعل على الاسلام المتطرف
السياسي وطالما ان انها تريد تاسيس دوله
خلافه فاننا اذا مشه فالخلاف كما تعلمون
امتدت في التاريخ من افغانستان الى الشرق
الاوسط شمال افريقيا والى اسبانيا ولطالما
ان هناك هناك عصابات متطرفه يريدون اعاده
تاسيس الخلافه الاسلاميه فان هذا الامر لن
ينتهي وان ايران ايضا عنصر يخل بالاستقرار
الى حد كبير
فايران والشيعه كا اسلام سياسي يواجهون
داعش وبالتالي فهم يحارون
سح ان ايران هي توسعيه وئ
من9 وخاصه منذ ان طاحت الثوره بالشا ايران
وان كل هدف ايران كان منذ ذلك الوقت هو
تصدير الثوره
الاسلاميه هذا يعني انهم يريدون الاستيلاء
على الشرق الاوسط والسيطره عليه ايران
تسيطر على عواصم العراق وسوريا واليمن
ولبنان وان نفوذ ايران يتد ويتوسع وسوء
الحظ هم يغذون الحرب الطائفيه فهم لديهم
قوات قائد قوات القدس
السليماني الذين يحاربون في تكريت وايران
تحاول زياده التوترات الطائفيه والسيطره
على كل شرق اوسط داعش تحاول ان تواجه
وتحارب ايران ولكن هي ايضا بدورها تريد
تحفيز واثاره المسلمين المعتدلين ولكنها
ايضا تستهدف المسيحيين واليهود واليزيدي
وكل من يقف في طريق تاسيس الخلافه
وبالتالي ان الاستراتيجيه العسكريه لن
تكون الا جزء من كل العمل علينا ان نوقف
هذه الاجيه السامه للاسلام السياسي وان
نخرج المعتدلين منها هل هذا ممكن دكتور
حيدر سعيد يعني خلال هذه السنوات
يمكن محاصره هذا التوتر الطائفي وتنامي
هذه الايديولوجيه
الطائفيه
يعني بالنهايه لكي نحلل الطائفيه الطائفيه
هي نتاج ازمه سياسيه يعني الصراع الطائفي
في العراق وفي المنطقه هو ليس صراعا
عقائديا ليكن هذا واضحا هذا ما يجمع عليه
من تناول وحلل ودرس وشرح وشرح المساله
الطائفيه في المنطقه الصراع ليس الصراع
على يوم السقيفه او صراع على فكره الامامه
او غيرها من الافكار العقائديه هناك راع
سياسي هناك ازمه في طبيعه ونموذج الدوله
في المشرق العربي لماذا اقول مشرق العربي
لاننا امام مجتمع متعدد الهويات ومتنوع
الدوله المشرقيه لم تستطع ان تنتج نموذجا
لاداره
التعدد عادل وكفو ويشرك سائر المكونات
والهويات في مؤسسه السلطه فبالتالي نمو
التنظيمات الراديكاليه في هذه
في طيات هذه الازمه السياسيه الصراع
الطائفي سينتهي متى ما وجدت مثل هذه
الدوله الدوله الناجحه والكفو في اداره
مثل هذا التعدد وعندما نقول انه داعش لن
تواجه فقط عسكريا بل الاولى هو هو
المواجهه السياسيه بمعنى نزع البيئه نعم
ولكن ولكن دكتور اذرني على المقاطعه ولكن
لا يبدو ان ذلك ك يعني تحقيق هذا التوازن
الطائفي السياسي من خ من خلال عمليه
سياسيه تنصف كل الطوائف قد لا يبدو هذا
شيئا سهلا وسؤال للدكتور ناجح الميزان
وزير الدفاع عندما سئل قال نحن نحاول دعم
حكومه متعدده الطوائف في العراق واذا
سالتني يقول وزير الدفاع الامريكي اذا
سالتني ما اذا كنا متاكدين من نجاح ذلك
فانا اقول كلا اذا الامريكان نفسهم ليسوا
متاكدين
من نجاح يعني وجود حكومه متعدده الطوائف
يعني المشكله ستبقى موجوده اليس
كذلك طبعا الحكومه الحكومه المتعدده هي مو
اشخاص يعني ان نجيب فلان هو سني او نجيب
فلان هو شيعي هي مو القضيه القضيه ما هي
قدره وما هي التمثيل الحقيقي لهذا الشخص
لمكون و
[موسيقى]
العمل على تحقيق مصالح المكون او الجهه او
المحافظه السؤال هو هذا نحن لم نرى يعني
منذ منذ الاحتلال ولحد الان لم نرى اريد
اخذ وزير الدفاع مثلا
سعدون
دورتين ولاخ محمد عبد القادر ايضا دوره
واليوم خالد العبيدي نرى انفصام بين
الوزير عندما يسل وزاره الدفاع ومنطقته
ويبدي ويبدا بتنفيذ المشروع الايراني يعني
هذا نقوله بصراحه اليوم التمثيل ليس حقيقي
للمناطق الغربيه وهذا مما دعى الى مظاهرات
واعتصامات واحتجاجات وبالتالي عندما تحاجج
يقول ممكم مزير الدفاع السني طبعا هي
اكذوبه اصلاح العمليه السياسيه تحتاج الى
كثير من العمل والى كثير من الحقيقه نحن
في كل مكان لماذا لا تعطون الاقاليم
للمحافظات لكي تتمكن كل محافظه من حكم
نفسها ضمن نظام فدرالي تعددي كان هذا كانه
اطلق في رؤوسهم عندما نطالب بهذا هذا قبل
سنوات والدستور يبرر هذا وموضوع في
الدستور ومواد دستوريه والحكم في العراق
يدور حول الفدراليه لكن
هناك عدم قبول اصلاح سياسي ولا يمكن اصلاح
سياسي الا باقام الاقاليم ولن تقوم
الاقاليم لانه تصريح خامنئي و وجميع
الحكومه الايرانيه بعدم السماح لاقامه
الفدراليه في العراق شكرا لك الدكتور نجح
الميزان الامين العام للمؤتمر التاسيسي
لاقليم صلاح الدين شكرا لك نشكر ايضا
ضيفين من عمان الدكتور حيدر سعيد مستشار
المركز العراقي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والاستاذ جيف جوردون المسؤول السابق في
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه شكرا لكم
جميعا لكم مننا اطيب المنى والسلام عليكم
ورحمه
[موسيقى]
الله